beach of sand is white dirt
i've been clear about what i call you
know
it's like there's not if you're drunk
[Music]
apparently
don't need your sober not needed you
sober then
i'm just talking about someone that i
had to
block
because he came to my he came to three
mikes and he was in when it was in
previews in new york
uh and he positive heckled it
meaning he was drunk going like yeah
to the point where i had to call him by
name and ask him to stop oh no it's a
wild time
2016
it was things were different i know
bianca how was your week honey um
well i got to tell you something
i think you're on to this old lady thing
that she got with me because
i've been dealing with an old lady
problem what do you got hip hips hip
dysplasia what do you got
oh
well
betrayal
[Music]
i have
moths
in where
in a cavity in your body no no it's not
me i have moms in my house
oh that's some old lady [ __ ] yeah i
didn't know having moths it was a thing
they're
it's a it's a disgusting do they have
like a nest or anything no no no they
just they just are they appeared i
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
eat your [ __ ]
so they're pantry moths apparently they
didn't know there was a thing that's the
highest class of mom
and it's a it was a disgusting mystery
uh i
didn't know mobs did that i i've never
had a problem with mods i
i love moths i never thought they were a
big deal
like i just never had a moth in my house
and they got my pantry so
now i'm knee deep i'm basically an
expert on moss at this point but
basically i got rid of like they're
they're gone now but i've been dealing
with it for
a week and what did you what uh doesn't
vinegar [ __ ] like that old ladies no no
no that's those are gnats oh no moths
you got to put traps and put like weird
smelling things cedar they don't like
cedar hmm do you like cedar i love cedar
oh it's more it's the same it's a
win-win i got cedar oils
sand and cedar just like i really am old
[ __ ] lady at this point so
my house smells like cedar but yeah put
it on your phonograph
your phonograph player
what have you been doing bianca
you know
i'm
not only i'm a podcasting comedian i
also direct commercial i would like to
make an announcement you guys which is
i had bianca come in and
she didn't come in she sent in a tape
for a new commercial i'm working on
and i have an announcement to make which
is you got a call back
no i didn't you did
what when it doesn't you don't get it
you just got a call back
like it just happened
well no they just said like i called you
back but then also the agency called you
back
so that's pretty cool
um
yeah
she's this much closer to being in
i
okay major bank commercial that i've
done commercials for in the past with a
captain car wrecks it rhymes with braves
as we know um and so i said this off the
podcast thank you very much but
it just meant a lot to me neil oh that i
brought you in thank you yes it's my
pleasure i you know what it is more than
anything
i
literally forget to bring people in
okay they go anybody you want to bring
in i'm like no no and now and then i'll
be in the audition i'll be like i know
40 people who could have done this
but i just forgot and this time i didn't
forget
and i brought in you thank you and i
thought i brought in fahim anwar but i
didn't see his tape um
so we'll see
actually a lot of people i know
are auditioning for it
there there were a lot of black women
i'll say that she was korean some would
say too many
there were a lot of black women uh there
was a there was a
it was a there were too many white
whatever so i did there were too many
white people auditioning as you guys get
ready
i am director of the future there were
too many white people right director bob
20 50.
too many white people you know who's
gonna you know who this news is gonna
grind
their gears as the guy who wrote to say
you gotta appreciate neil moore oh the
guy who said i'm the best thing that
ever happened i mean i mean you're wrong
if he's wrong he's not
he's not wrong
what did you call this i called you free
sneakers
um
so i had to do [ __ ] on that i had to do
uh i did go location scout
for uh where are we going
you're going
if you
you're going to see me valley girl wow
let me bring my hands
we found uh most malls are abandoned now
so we found a mall where we can do our
exterior walking out of the drugstore
and then i had to marry that with a
couple outdoor restaurants and spaces
and i had to go to i had to go to
[ __ ]
aqua don't i had to go to a bunch of
places
sorry
i
so i just had to drive around
do you like driving around i don't think
you do don't
hate it
problem is if i'm
i have a real problem with to doing two
things at once
meaning people are like i'm a good
multitasker which nobody is but
i i'm pretty good no but it's
statistically it's been proven no it's
good
so i know everyone
no one's good
i literally cannot remember things
i will
i will have a conversation with somebody
or put something answer an email
if i'm driving or on the i don't
remember it yeah so
so if i've had a conversation with you
and it seems like
i'm driving
it's not legally binding because i
blacked out i can't remember do you if
this wasn't recorded would you remember
podga
no i remember
i remember
you know why because i actually sounded
like seinfeld no no um
i don't
remember people when people talk about
something on the podcast i remember like
if i say something
extra funny i will remember jimmy carr
called yesterday he called it i like
that it's like overseas yeah jimmy
called in he scraped some money together
and he reminded me of something that i
did remember saying but
it was the funny thing you said she's
asian but not curvy or not
uh sort of sexy and
not sexy and smooth and i said so
filipino
and then
jimmy was like
i loved
[Music]
[Laughter]
no we had a nice talk oh by the way
we need songs we're putting out on all
points well it's time for songs and uh
not graphics more songs but if you can
do graphics we need bing's going to
apologize we always needed that i know
we good job neil good one deal how about
good one neil attaboy neal no at a boy
neal that a boy bird's so good
good one neil is funnier good one neil
um we have the rest of them are good and
we need a new logo
which i'm working on
i have a secret
you'll see no you'll all see when i
unleash my new logo i'm clutching my i'm
pulling my robe clothes clothes to
georgia
i don't this is an old man phrase that
i've never even heard okay but i think
republicans are going with
if you can't beat them cheat em
they've said that i just oh i made it up
but i didn't make there's no way oh we
need a new neil's old man phrases
because will made that himself and it's
too long
and the mix is bad i'm sorry that
there's i really don't like that song
it's not he's not a musician i know that
but that's why
i was like
no musician would let that leave the
leave the audience in will's defense
it's better than anything
anybody who's not a musician could have
could have done so
that's impossible to say i mean that's
not i mean i'm just giving him some
credit like that's better that's like
the worst that's the faintest praise
i've ever heard wait let me just i'm
just saying in my opinion i couldn't do
that you will you are the tallest dwarf
could you do something yes
oh i could do yeah because i know how to
lay tracks out oh okay and i you know
i'm friends with yeah that prince a lot
of these musicians so i get why i get
how they think
fine by the way this is a side note but
the best part
of
amir
quest love thompson is
his encyclopedia he
he posted a thing yesterday about on
instagram about
the
the synthesizer technology that stevie
wonder used for like three albums in a
row right and they got i've seen the
documentary but it was the guys who two
[ __ ] white like goofballs
who created that sound that like
that that stevie wonder sound it was two
white dudes and he posted like an
eight-minute documentary go watch it if
you like me it's just like
the best part of a mirror where he can
just go like
like paragraphs about these guys the
technology the records the studio that
it was awesome i he amir is a living
legend i he got me through a lot of
quarantine i did i watched his
um what were they called the record
store amir's record store the sessions
is what it was called
um
and that's how it was spelled
um yeah and he do what he do it on one
artist that james brown won yeah
you can't believe
the knowledge this is stevie once stevie
called in
oh he did wait stevie wonder called in
during when he was doing a stevie block
okay and then i gotta go
i gotta re-watch it because they were
they were so good they're incredibly
long they're six yeah they're like four
to six hours long so but if you're
driving somewhere it's
background just playing and
side note
he got
um
the
uh he's the music director of the oscars
now
oh i saw that
where i would at a point good job neil
not when i met him
he
2003
we had done
in season a spell show
i had a
i'd beef if you can believe it with our
music supervisor
our music it's a long story he tried
the guy who would make cues for us
is a friend of mine
and he made cues he before chappelle
show he made cues for
robert schmeichel's tv fun house yeah
and i would see him
[ __ ] procrastinate on smygal and i
said if you do this to me
i'm gonna fire you
and he did it to me and you know what i
did bianca i
yeah yell
fingers long story short
we had an opening
in music no one knew that
talking to
amir at the punch line in san francisco
after one of dave's shows and he said
amir said i would like to be bill conte
who was the music director of the oscars
and i and i was like i'll give you a job
and it all paid off guys
amir is going to be doing the music for
the oscars which means pretty much
nothing to anybody
but
it's cool
how much
how much influence do the people that
run the awards ceremony have it's kind
of an establishment it's a different
yeah when they're like the director yeah
they bring on different producers every
year like soda burger is a producer this
year they kind of
they can affect they have to get it they
have to run it by the oscars so it's
like it's their it's just new
it's three new members of an
eight-person jury right
um
it's even so work i've been watching a
lot of nick because it came on did you
ever watch the neck
i never watched the neck it's good
yeah a good thing it's good people i'm
i'm a hypochondriac so it's
i've
convinced myself and i've unconvinced
myself
i
had nasal syphilis
that's a very funny that's a funny level
for women to get to where you're
watching
shows about 1800s medical things going i
think i have it i the lady came in with
a metal nose i'm like i will not
i will this will not be it may it i was
like i have i don't know and then i went
i deep dived get me 1800
uh
yeah so um so georgia voting can't beat
him cheat him
it's so weird it's so
it's so it's very blatant but when you
read it it's like
basically dude was this from 1800 was
this talk about it in the 1800s
yeah like that's a republican party
where you go what are you doing can't
bring water can't bring water
they basically changed it to where they
have
so much power to throw out votes
to deem certain elections like invalid
uh and they can
congress
the
center american government congress can
override them though my understanding
i thought it said it throughout the
ability for the vice president to
all right who knows i know it's it's
something i'm under the impression that
they something can be done something can
be done i think something cool is the
filibuster
[ __ ]
[Music]
um now i don't know if you saw sometimes
biden is so old
it's
hilarious and
seth took a little shot at him the other
day i haven't seen trevor take a little
shot at him but will you look up
jim crow jim eagle
it's all designed and i'm going to spend
my time doing three things
one
trying to figure out how to pass the
legislation passed by the house
number one number two
educating the american public
the republican voters i know
find this despicable
republican voters
the folks out in the
outside this white house i'm not talking
about
the the elected officials i'm talking
about voters
voters
and so i'm convinced pause this he's at
80 capacity i'm looking at i mean from
when he was
work for
obama yeah like he's he is
he's
it's
i don't know what to i'm glad it's like
he's better than trump but make no
mistake
that guy is not at full strength which
is a
that which is it's a funny criticism on
the role of the president because you
can be
yeah 80 percent it's you're just a ins
you're a figurehead it's whatever you're
a fake
you're uh you're all i need to do is
vote the ways i want you to i don't need
you to leave me i don't mean like i i
it's
i would you are a symbol so he's like a
dignified man right we don't need a
father figure though like it's it's fine
um keep going we'll be able to stop this
because it is the most pernicious thing
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
this is
gigantic so right there that's a guy go
i look as a guy who goes get him a
podcast who goes for one
from time to time that doesn't land
um
the great thing is he he goes like
it's like ah
jim eagle the funny thing nobody knows
what the [ __ ] he's talking about and he
realizes at that point
like i should have run that password
right like
okay i saw what i was going for
i don't even what's the metaphor
well okay but where is the where is the
or for the for politics where's the or
the politicians it's your office
yeah you're like guys yeah tell me does
this metaphor work
uh
there's no hallway there's no hallway at
the white house reading but is this
[ __ ] metaphor that jim crow looks
like jimmy angle you'll be like what
he's so old though you do think for a
second
he
no i i think he somebody did they try to
explain jim eagle
on one of these
there was one of those
linked to was
what before this was what is jim eagle
being used it was our analogy at a press
conference yesterday and it caused a lot
of confusion who was jim eagle
uh
there's no answer
um jim eagle is so funny who is
it
jim eagle is an actual person
joe biden made up the name as a play on
words swing in a miss
the king of swings and misses he's uh
what was that guy's name joe joe the
plumber and jimmy eagle lived together
jeff was real though he was um
jimmy
jim eagle lives with the with the um
with the welfare queen
uh in a in a in an apartment
they're these are fake american
characters
um okay
so joe biden's very old jimmy it's a
bigger issue which is he'll probably die
yeah you think in office
i would bet money he's gonna die in
office
i don't think he's like
i'm not it's he
he's pretty good at his age
i wouldn't say he's good for his age my
mom's 87 she's she's better yeah
but
um
it's it's a mental
faculties thing so
what i'm not saying we invoke the 25th
amendment or answer my worry for
democrats is i don't think
kamala would win an election
and they're going to be hard-pressed to
push her out they're going to be
hard-pressed not to run her yeah of
course so be weird like oh
it's like the first uh black vp oh but
they have changed the law only obama
could run
above her
or like the rock i mean like it would
take a supernatural person or of course
jim angle jimmy um
okay so
on did you see the cdc finally
she's
in so much she's she's underneath you
know what it is this is like
so basically if you don't know what
about the the cdc woman the
she's the head of the cdc right
her green screen is not great it's
yeah um it looks like a graphic in a
in a campaign ad or like a a
drug ad
um pharmaceutical lab um
she is basically saying
is there a good part of this
she basically part where she's like
i'm gonna go off book
i don't know you could hit play yeah we
have so much to look forward to
so much promise and potential of where
we are and so much reason for hope
but right now i'm scared
um i know what it's like as a physician
to stand in that patient room down
but as your sister
positive
she hit me with uh as a mother as a as a
which when you evoke all of them it's a
big you know it's a big deal like um
nothing sells so good to me until you
start telling me your other identities
other than
credible person
you don't have to be a credible person
if you're also a mommy
now
mommy trumps everything
this now the the easy are gonna be
women's too emotional which uh it's not
even worth it no what i would say is
it's a why did i take on a job expecting
americans to cooperate no she's seen
some she's like a babysitter who's it's
like a problem child
who meets the parents at the front door
yeah like we're we have so much to look
forward to yes but these [ __ ]
are crazy they won't wear masks they
don't think i'm they think the that the
vaccine is fake like it's did she
realize what the job is right
and
she's gone berserk
sir
she's got a version of woke psychosis
she's got like she's so [ __ ] stressed
out in this video i feel
so bad for you know what she's like i
had a sub that
the our main teacher got pregnant and
she had to take leave and then the the
ta took over and we were like yes high
school college this is in elementary
school whoa and
this is like amazing great not like she
she was clearly like shadowing her to
take over we just didn't know
she was like she's my helper right and
you thought they were lesbians
and so then she took over and she was
young and like
clearly wanted to get into teaching and
we ran this lady into the ground
and these are not you didn't go to a
black grade school no this isn't like
the inner city slapping the tits
upstairs every kid is an [ __ ] that's
not if they'll be they'll be as big an
[ __ ] as they can be they're this is
everyone thinks it's dangerous minds
like this white kids act crazy as well
yeah everyone she would do this thing
where she would hold two
fingers in the air
and she's like when you see me holding
two fingers in there you hold two
fingers in the air and be quiet
she would be standing for 15 minutes i'm
like great this is so ineffective people
walking around here
oh
i love little kids when they're
when they're why feral kids very funny
um i'm trying to we didn't really have
any bad
you didn't have it was holy catholic and
chicago like
chicago catholic
not there were some nuns that caught at
high school but did they hit
uh no it was after hitting
um
you didn't you weren't part of an unruly
class
no
not really i mean we we got in we did
some dirt what did you do we i'll tell
you what we did
okay so there was a we were going to see
a you know when there's a field trip
it's like
yeah it's [ __ ] it's on it's on so we
were going to see god's spell
and look at that it's a like a christian
musical okay like hair or any [ __ ] and
um
and uh
it's like the less cool version of hair
oh that's a kind of a tight poster it is
pretty tight um
so we
my my
parents were going out of town
so
i believe i had duh boys over
before school before school so eight a.m
to drink
at eight a.m what
we were just trying to get [ __ ] turnt
and lit
we didn't pre-game for good pregame for
we preschooled and um
we
so
some we drank a little bit at my house
then we go to school
peop [ __ ] morons drank in the parking
lot with this is a classic case of
you've all got to be on the same page
and you've all got to have your story
straight yeah beforehand you don't know
that though going in you're when you're
15.
and uh so one of them got popped and
then slowly the [ __ ] the net
tightened no and i was in class and i
heard the footsteps coming i was like
this is for me
i know this is for me and sure enough
boop
got pulled in the funniest part was
i'm walking toward
the principal's office and another kid
who was part of the crew is walking the
other way yeah and the closer i get to
him
i realize he's crying
and he literally does like a pass like
we cross each other
and as we cross he goes we're [ __ ]
dead man
so goddamn that's what
um if whatever you're writing can it be
a flashback in your one
because that was great there were a
couple great moments where a kid there
was like a parent's try being on one of
the kids was like i just wanted to taste
it that [ __ ] was hilarious
um
now the now the super duper punch line
is the
the hooch that we drank
was stolen from the school
in a in a bizarre weird like like
yeah it was like a the christian
brothers which are like male
nuns okay um
uh
they
they we stole
scotch or something from their house it
was pretty wild
um so we're [ __ ] dead
man how much trouble did you get in
i think i got grounded for a month maybe
that seems light compared to the the
rules we i think got suspended the
problem was
i think i got suspended but it was like
i was it was all like kind of the
highest ranked
kids in the class but it's catholic
school they didn't know we stole it from
them okay it's catholic they have to
it's what they have to like they gotta
make a show but it was like what is this
a problem of people drinking before
school
um like this is that we have to make a
show because if we don't stop this now
it's going to be rampant it's going to
look like a uh
outside veterans stadium before an
eagles game eagles are good jimmy
football um
so and they tore down veterans stadium
um
so i'm old you see
um so
so that was pretty great
um so yeah i never had a crazy sub
oh you never had a game we did have
crazy babysitters
really but not they weren't we had one
i remember one who was like that lady
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they got rid of her and then we had
it was more if you know what it was i
remember we had
a couple babysit for us and meanwhile
it's like i bought six of us probably
yeah they needed
yeah and at one point my sister i
remember a knife was drawn
what and it was pretty wild who drew
nora of course oh
uh nora brennan had took a knife out for
some reason was going to kill peter i
believe was the threat
but i felt like ah this isn't the best
representation do you have our family
have you ever wanted to write
like a partridge family but
the not pot you know because i feel like
you have a lot of i think that's what i
never watched what's the show with bill
macy on showtime
oh uh shameless yeah i think that's kind
of what they're going for it's not a
bunch of them but they're meant to be
like wild as opposed to
like a
family either wild or you're not i mean
like you either if you're gonna do one
of those shows you can't do like
peter threatens to kill nora it's like
not right it's gotta be
meth i mean i watch skills and thrills
so so you got it you get it you know
that's a that was a shout out for your
skill for my skills and thrills all
right i had a knife story
and i'm and i faked the rest of it just
to get the knife in there
um
so
rest in power queen cdc lady
uh i i may i don't know i mean i i get
it you see how
do you think that's gonna handle that
[ __ ] pretty well here's the thing
so many people are getting
right you have a new love for dr burks
and dr fauci well have you watched the
doc i didn't watch the cnn one word
burke said yeah four hundred thousand
people died unnecessarily
whoops
um
well no what's funny is they i even they
in terms of covet cases
there was a thing where it was a it's a
pesky number fifty five thousand fifty
to sixty five thousand it's like
the numbers not pesky
people are [ __ ] dumb don't put this
on comments being pesky
no people are [ __ ] stupid and they
won't do the the thing that they have to
do
we just wear a cloth over your [ __ ]
face you imbecile
i heard that right now florida has two
million cases
florida i again
someone made the point like you
florida's had two million cases had
maybe had uh you can't the the like that
per day like total cases yeah they've
had two million um but california's had
four
um so
yeah
actually this the u.s has had sorry
okay florida yeah you're right uh i'm
bad with charts uh what numbers
what that's cuba um the uh
the
you with florida you've i've read an
article that's like when you think it's
bad it then comes back and when you
think it's good it gets it's just you
can't florida's like
not you're not you're gonna go broke
betting on what's gonna happen in
florida um
do you think i mean i don't know i feel
like if people are getting vaccinated
it's almost like if it's surging in
florida
oh
i don't know if californians are gonna
care about that kind of surge i don't
care about a surge that isn't near me
yeah
which is maybe a little callous but well
maybe no i just mean i'm the same but
it's weird i don't think it's
i don't if you're not i can't worry
about every state's law i just can't
it's like i i'd be constantly worried
right about like they're you'd look like
this
in montana
yeah i'd be like
look guys we have so much to look
forward to i swear as a comic yeah um
i'm talking to you as a mommy
um
so
now you saw that by april 19th
90 of the country will be able to get
vaccinated within five miles of their
house which is pretty sweet that's cool
but that sounded like a very politician
thing
they like to put within you'll get right
they need if i five times
yeah you can walk that's the point is
people that don't have cars can walk and
and
again
people will find a way to complain about
it
no no i'm not i'm not complaining about
that i just think it's
why set yourself up for not being able
because i don't think they've i think
they've
they can
scale it out they can do the projections
and go oh we can get if we place these
things everywhere they're being
strategic about it which i know sounds
crazy based on what we're used to in
america i mean it's true i i just
there's a lot
here you know it's not that crazy but a
lot of people don't live near things you
know a lot of people don't live near a
cvs in america
uh well they're not all cbs's they've
got they've got that they've picked i
don't think they would say it if they
didn't have it if they don't have no
because they look like
morons if they say it if they say it
can't back it up if they say it and
don't spray
um
it
a good there's something there if you
got to say it sprint
uh
is jim eagle
um the
we're gonna be able to get vacs which uh
i'm very
curious what are you gonna do
make out with you oh finally
all right
um
finally thank you president biden
um
yeah april 19th that's the that's the
drop dead date but here's the thing that
i'm going to find something negative
it's you're not going to be
partying april 20th
no you're going to be like let's say
once you get the shot it doesn't it
takes two weeks to work
and then
it you if it's moderna it's a month
later
so
plan a you're at least it's even if you
get it april 19th
you're not partying you're not [ __ ]
you're not raw dog until the 26th
can i tell you something kind of shitty
i'd love it i'd love to hear it i read
an article that
older people
the vaccines like significantly less
effective within six months
where do you read that
it's like they the the antibodies are
like gone
don't care unless it's young beautiful
people in california so bushfire and
visionary
don't care sweetie that's a brush fire
in mid
montana
um
okay so we're everybody please get
immunized
if you're
here just please do it please
um
now
you can borrow my bike
if it's the speedy
i got a cup actually my
my my uh scooter yeah wow
so anyhow
now okay here's something interesting
now the cuomo
brothers
are
under hot under fire now what did chris
do
he
well
andrews of maura yeah yeah like just the
the thing about the cuomo brothers you
look at them
and they're not
they don't look that smart
no they they read a little dim they read
confident
they read like
maybe charismatic in the right situation
especially chris
but they read a little different that is
though we are
stereotyping east coasters don't sound
super smart to me when they have that
accent
forget about what do you talk that kind
of thing
i think stereotyping that i don't that's
not my issue i
having
grown immune to the i mean i no i've
tried jokes
i wanted to do a joke about if you want
to not be scared of edgar allan poe
edgar allan poe's writing hear it in a
baltimore accent where he's from
said the raven it's just like it gets
the [ __ ] out of here um so
those that's not the issue so the issue
is
the andrew's gonna get probably popped
out of
out of office okay the bigger issue is
they
uh that he got when chris got sick
andrew got him special access to testing
and people are saying that that's wrong
and cnn released a statement like we
don't get involved and all that stuff
i think you gotta
well that's one of those things where
like
what do you think's gonna happen guys
if your brother's the governor
and you get an illness
he didn't get him a vaccine he got him a
test
to see if how sick he if he was sick or
not like i guess it's a scandal but
that's one of those things like
it's like when he wasn't trying to get
yeah
and not didn't have a stupid brother
that was the governor
um
yeah so that's what it's like i can't
really no who that's that's a scam
they're trying to make it a scandal but
i kind of think everyone that hears
about it's like i would test back
especially when he got sick
that was
high high anxiety you and i got antibody
tests yeah
come and get us
we had antibody tests from uh like from
your hookup yeah
not even not even the government not
even the love gov as they're gonna i'm
sure they've called them on
that's what they used to call spencer
really uh beloved the the new york post
has horrible great headlines um
the love gov um
so
yeah like stop it like get him on the
sex stuff
that's fine yeah but i'm gonna chris
yeah all right here's a here's an in all
right here's here's a here's an argument
there they came at andrew cuomo because
he hired
he would hire women in some cases by
physical type
not like they weren't unqualified but he
would
they would go you look like
you look like you were like a waitress
like a hooters type thing
whatever
so my question is
do you think men aren't getting hired
for looks
yeah everyone is hot everyone's getting
hired for looks in the world yeah
everyone's getting hired for hype
looks
is charisma
not a reason to hire someone like where
they're trying to draw the line like he
hired attractive women
um and it's kind of like
you can't really
good luck legislating against that
good luck like
really good luck
like the water that makes the don't give
water to people in line seem
enforceable
right whereas
you can't hire people based on looks
you'd say you just never say that
you go oh she seems smarter
and you wink
and then they don't catch it in the
wiretap
i watch this
random 2020
you know they like don't do journalism
so just experiment on people what would
you do yeah it wasn't that it was
something else um it was spills and
shells spills and chips
and uh they sent
two
good looking people and two uh
you know not as like just regular
looking people out in new york in a very
touristy area and they were all lost
they just had a map and were pretending
to be like
which way
everyone helped please the lost
attractive couple yeah everyone no so
few people helped the unattractive
couple i think one person yeah that was
also ugly another idol
a fellow ugg
so and they did it in so many different
scenarios mm-hmm that it was blatantly
clear that they like attracted and we
like to be close to each other yes it's
the it's like being it's a god it's a
it's the closest you can get to a god
you can't believe that's extreme no i
believe that's what it is it's
proof of god
it's like michael jordan is so good at
basketball you go
ah he must know god or something or
lebron's so big you're like
[ __ ] that i don't know
i got i'm going to stay near that
because that's
seems like you don't want to go away
look up right exactly he's got some kind
of celestial hook up now guys the joke's
on you because i have the celestial hook
up and i've been clear about that but
in life
death is a comma
um
so that's what it's like cleanliness
cleanliness is next to godliness it's
like attractiveness it's like it's is
and talent
and it's hard to believe michael jackson
wasn't some way ordained to the point
where you're like i don't want to press
charges against this [ __ ] guy i'm
going to get in trouble
with whatever made that is going to be
mad at me for
enforcing so
this idea that you can't hire for
attractiveness
i thought of two jokes when you were
talking about it there alex baez wrote a
joke
for tina and amy on the golden globes
uh the intro was for
there it was an intro
and it was uh
like a young super mod like a young
supermodel's warm vagina please welcome
leonardo dicaprio
that's good did they use it yes okay uh
that's a bey's special one of the best
maybe the best joke writer alive and
secondly
colin quinn had a joke in one of his
shows where
when you're
when you're ugly and you enter a room
the everyone's like what
when you're good-looking it's like hey
can i help you when you're ugly it's
like what what do you want
like
what
um you're [ __ ] this up they get out
of here
i mean it's i mean think about it when
you're young
who has cooties the fat kid
yeah when you're
old according to me according to me a
month ago
and by cooties you mean diabetes correct
folks
do you mean comorbidities
what cuties you mean co-morbidities who
doesn't you can't spell cooties without
co-morbidity
then okay well when we were young we had
a cootie shot so what's the cutie shot
when you're old
uh
insulin
okay
from what i can tell and the vaccine
and the the pfizer
um
oh the boat got free yeah like today
yeah i i did i gotta say i never felt
passion for this story no neither did i
was like no passion
suez canals
you wanted to hit me with the
panama
and even all the stuff of like prices
are going to go up and yeah yeah
yeah this is they did 12
this
this number blew my mind
400 million dollars
worth of
goods passes through the suez canal
an hour
that's something that's and so for seven
days
we'll figure that number out
um
no no no not him
please will
edit yourself out no one can
we'll erase your
memory um but when you do see we were
saying if you told me the number it's
like who knows but when you say
400 million dollars an hour yeah
that's my i can say that yeah but even
that i don't really care because none of
it's my merch so i didn't i never cared
i don't it maybe it's my aversion to the
sea
i don't love
boats i don't like tankers i don't like
seafood tankers tankers
i like tankers but not tankers um you
know what i mean i don't like seafood i
don't like fish i don't like seaweed i
don't like scuba diving
scoob i've never done i don't mind a
snorkel snorkel snorkel
i don't mind a snorkel if it's 78
degrees minimum in the water i can get
down with that uh and
so no maritime
interest
don't i mean if someone invited me on a
rich if a rich person that my friends
know said come on so so-and-so's yacht i
might go because you'd still think about
it a little bit i would i'd slow i'd let
them know the last day
i'd slow play although i do like
vacationing to a beach you like looking
at water you just don't want anything i
don't want to i like looking at i don't
mind a jet ski although if there's no
waves it gets old in 40 seconds
um
and
beach of sand is white
dirt i've been clear about what i call
you name and
um
so
so rest in power suez canal boat i never
cared for you
but i'm glad you're free
um i could relate as a person that's
been stuck in relationships he didn't
want to be
just jack knife yeah and that in that
way i really was rooting for you
um
now this is a cancellation issue this is
so
wild so my kind of viral yes
um
a gentleman
named jensen carp
who is
who is it l.a guy
the producer
uh a television guy i guess yeah he did
um he
he produced got the mic yeah he he
produced uh dropped the mic dropped the
mic which i'd heard he stole he's
dropped the mic
the one with method man
this one with chrissy i think no that's
that's lip sync battle uh drive the mic
was the one where like shaq your feet
are too it's bad it's just my nightmare
it was called my nightmare it was oh
okay uh go back to that other article
thank you um wait he soul dropped the
mic
that's what the headline said
um
so
anyhow he
found a shrimp tail in his cinnamon
toast crunch
and
made
made a thing about it on twitter
it goes viral he's married to
the woman who'd played topanga on boy
meets world yeah so
it's all and then what then then this is
like a a good uh you know
lesson here which is keep your head
below the parapet if i may be an old man
that is a war phrase
is the basically the like the trench
where they can see you yeah it's but the
parapet is like the
i think it's raised it's like a crow's
nest in uh
schindler's list okay um anyhow
he raised his head above the parapet
and he got a bunch of
not me twos me also i as well guys wells
he got many eyes as well
uh he got a few eyes wells from
uh he got one from a woman named uh
melissa stetten who i follow on
twitter and i believe she's read for
uh commercial
um does she have a callback she did get
a call back
so something to think about [ __ ] uh
called him a manipulative gaslighting
narcissist ex-boyfriend who once told me
he was surprised i didn't kill myself
because my life was so worthless that is
cruel when i this is one of those things
where i hear about other guys and i
first of all give myself a good job neil
and i can't i not like i should be
surprised but i
kind of can never believe i believe them
but i'm like i can't believe guys are
like this you yeah i told you one like
uh
a guy like around my school just asked
me for the time just dick out
just dick out when i was a kid like it
and not boy i'm talking about boyfriends
i'm not talking about like my mom has a
shitload of stories about people uh
flashing her when she was younger really
it's one of these weird things you bring
up the 30s
and within
a minute my mom's gonna talk about
people flashing her
and i it creeps me out every time and
there's nothing i can do about it okay
so you are not surprised i'm not
surprised by
uh the general riffraff of of male
you know of male behavior
what i am surprised by is guys
dating
adult women
as adults who all are in the kind of the
same industry or like very
connected
acting like this yeah that's crazy like
and then i think about the [ __ ] i feel
bad about like i feel bad
people think this is mean i don't know
i've ever said something
i said to a girlfriend at one point
i said you're not as healthy as i
thought you were
that's the most neal [ __ ]
you know i said it then
it was pretty early
was this mentally or physically
uh
like did she eat bad and you didn't know
or did she not work out about her
behavior and her
this wasn't about it was about like
inter
emotional [ __ ]
what did she say i uh she cried and a
bunch of people said it's very mean i'm
like
i don't think that's me i think that's
like i thought you were healthier
you carry yourself is the thing with
women is you guys
present very healthy
stationary smell good hair makeup
wardrobe
uh
that's neither here nor there
the fact that this
happens to like that
women with
like followings
like that he's doing this
or he did it allegedly to these women is
like
that's where i get like
how tone deaf are you
that you would do that
even five years ago yeah guys are tone
deaf though i mean
they can be this is like a weird control
thing though it feels like behind that
he seems like light-hearted and fun
and there's a control situation yeah i
mean this the all i can say is in some
ways
uh makes me feel good about me why why
is
i think the worst thing you could write
is like
neil
had a thing where he would say this is a
two apology offense
you know what i mean like i almost wish
someone would write one of these and
then people would a think it's funny
or b
go like this isn't an article right um
now my argument against this is
um
like
is
it's not illegal
right
being an [ __ ] yeah
so
now he'll be
treated like he committed a crime
yeah
but what's the crime
like
so that's where i go like unfavorably
unfavorable what what do we so
i'm all again i he um he should not have
treated
if the the what they said is true
he should not have treated a
young lady like that but
on the other hand
seems out of proportion
there's no proportion to any of this
[ __ ] like so now
we're all gonna again maybe it is but
someone now i now i'm uh misogynistic
because i'm not like you should be able
to attack a guy or a woman in public
for how they were in a relationship even
though it wasn't
a physical transgression it's just an
[ __ ]
well you know a lot of people and i know
so many more people
than anyone so
i've met
okay guys so if one of them goes viral
for something innocuous
i feel like you have uh
you know
what i heard type of story not like you
say it but you have you have that
knowledge oh i yeah you just wouldn't
say it but yeah
if you were a different type of person
you might be you might want to put
someone on bust you know
right
but i feel like it's just i don't know
it's not like i don't have the
ammunition you have course i do but look
i'm walk i'm a walking grenade
uh what i'm saying is therapy yeah and a
parapet
uh not an epaulette that's on the sleep
you're gonna get them confused trust me
i've been knowing both of them for about
20 years and it's been a heck of a ride
um great guys the
yeah i but i wouldn't
you know what i mean some people will
and the other thing you know what i
heard right but the other thing that i i
don't know if i've said on the show
guys never
do this
to each other it does seem like it's a
lot more women
it's usually women and gay men
interested in gaming here guys right but
here let me finish okay because they
will not have to fight the guy
under any circumstances
so you think there's i'm positive
i'm positive that's why i'm not even
going to let you finish the question
the reason more guys why don't you
condemn cause it because i'm gonna have
to fight him and he'll beat me up
neal's gonna have to do this tennis
shoes which is why
guys always say
call the cops
call the cops whenever there's a problem
i always say call the cops call get the
get get get uh litigation involved
because i don't want to have to fight
that person which i will have to do if i
can
fight publicly
there is someone now
who may want to fight me because of
something i said on twitter
that was standing with
uh uh i'm basically condemning this guy
so what i'm saying is women think men
are cowards and i say i'm not a coward
i'm a [ __ ] taxpayer call the cops i
paid for them okay call the cops fair
enough
yes
yeah
so
what i'm saying is if you're in showbiz
uh as a guy
and you date women in showbiz
be nice to them
uh be nice to any woman but that's
that's the problem with dating people
you work with is it all it's all [ __ ]
connected and also breaking up no very
rarely do people have a good breakup i'm
not saying it was just a regular breakup
but
people do really shitty things in
breakups that you're like you are blown
away by that you remember
he was nice but at the end
he acted like a [ __ ] [ __ ] yes and
i've had by the way women also do
horrible things i know yeah
but and the reason guys don't out women
is because they don't want to fight
their new boyfriend
that's why that's why you never see guys
go ah cause i'm gonna have to i don't as
i said to somebody i don't know
if he did
the thing he's accused of but i do know
that i don't have time to take karate
classes four nights a week
to fight him the funny part is that this
situation
kind of
didn't end up that bad for cinnamon
toast crunch
you'd think they came out on top they
came out this is not a
finger in the chili wendy's scandal this
is where you're going
um
finger in the chili's wendy's scandal
where everyone's like i know it was fake
but
i don't want the
chili for a little bit yeah it hasn't
hasn't dimmed my life for cinnamon toast
crunch one bit
not one knob on wheels lights
um
so come on let's do it
little nas x
did you see the video
it's fantastic
although apparently a little little
little stolen little stolen jensen carp
um
yeah apparently it's a little stolen
which
also was the devil eric andre
i don't think it was okay
um
now they're mad
well
that
there i have a few thoughts on this
which is
he killed satan at the end
so oh no it's not in the small looked
like anywhere no that's not you're
racist no i'm not um you're a racist
person you think all black people look
like eric you think all devils look like
erica
um
i was i'll say this for for um
for little nausea
uh
looks like he's having a very good time
being a young gay man
good for him god [ __ ] bless i think
that's what i well i was watching him
going like this kid's having a [ __ ]
good time i like watching people have
enjoy
themselves and he's enjoying it of
course he's absolutely i'm not i say
that with absolute
he's like being
he's being like
performatively yeah he's being very uh
uh
aggressively homosexual
and but he's he's do he's
unapologetically unapologetically
aggressively whatever you want to call
it
um i love it he's moisturized he's in
good shape moist uh he's wearing like
he's he's wearing like women's boots
it's all a little android he's got a lot
going on
the devil [ __ ] him he [ __ ] the devil
although i don't know if he [ __ ] him i
think he twerks on him he twerked on him
and look if he if the devil
something got somewhere else
who might have judged the devil
be that bts but yeah um i also think
there's a section of this song that's
got a legitimately great melody oh um
again
over there
um
and what i would say is
he's people so christians and
republicans are fake mad at them
are people worried about satan first of
all he brought satan back
he brought someone back like he satan
can do personal appearances again
he is his privates are gonna go his his
pa agent is gonna blow up
um
what i'm
so that's like oh yes satan i forgot
about satan we forgot we even heard
satan yeah it's hilarious the amount of
misspellings to satin
very funny
um
so
i don't know i think it's the drop of
blood
they don't like it yeah but and the
other thing is first of all nike had to
distance themselves nike was like you
know what's no you know what's [ __ ] up
when nike's like hey
do this you know what we're about child
labor
and asian sweatshops that's us and
markups
but this satan this blood stuff come on
guys
um apparently satan
uh said he wants something to do with it
so that's pretty wise
who um
so okay he's having a blast haven't been
a young guy this was like the thing that
everyone did in the 80s
all of heavy metal was about satan and
judas priests and the [ __ ] horns
they were mad then
and
if little nazix thinks
this is like
controversial now
this is to that thing where they're
kissing at the end of the at the aids at
the hiv meds whether it's like dude this
would have gotten you
in 1990 if he done this
i don't know they would have shot him
into outer space
like there's no they would have been so
they were just from this
yeah like we don't know
we don't know how to comprehend this
like you think about what madonna was
controversial for right like dancing
sexy in a wedding dress
okay blowing jesus was it blowing jesus
i don't know if she blew him even i
think she did i think she
black jesus
what are you
madonna the problem with madonna and
jesus yeah
uh it's yeah like yeah leon was jesus
leon was jesus of course it was leon
and i it was like they were just they
didn't like using that christian imagery
yeah they didn't and uh
in chris listen in christianity's
defense
they got the best imagery of all they
have religions look i've always said
they do they really do it's like kevin
christie made the observation the isis
flag
the flag of isis fantastic black white
lettering
it's like the it's like the the
aromantics from last week
uh that's a heck of a flag isis it's
because it looks homemade
but it's not yeah it's like a vintage
yeah uh poster yes
um i love the all fl all lives matter
flag is so black and white no just a
black and white flag all lives matter
black black lives matter no no no the
all lives matter one well they have the
blue that's stupid but
usually it's not it doesn't look that
bad it's like toned down so i believe
it's the cover of stanconia that's what
you're is what you're talking about it's
a i think even some rappers started
wearing it rather than play a little
come on
and they're like don't wear that flag
it's like oh i just thought i was out
cast
it's not your fault but
no no no
so i'm i'm i follow little nas x on
twitter
because of this he got me take this flag
off
he got me and
what's funny is that
christians
even recently have spent so much time
and effort attacking gay people not
accepting them
yeah trying to reproduce
they drove them and to say where else
were they gonna go
you won't take them satan will make them
a cake
i'll tell you that
satan will make you a cake so why are
you mad that they are
making a mockery of your symbolism who
cares
it's there's no christianity in it it's
all satan [ __ ] so
you know
who owns that right who's who's symbol
who's who's image well that is kind of
christian because a lot of religions
don't have the idea of hell or satan
yeah
like judaism doesn't have it buddhism
doesn't have it
there isn't that that is kind of a
christian
symbol
yeah uh but
i guess they have demons in other ones
but or
things like that but uh i
why are you mad you're you just
literally the pope just said it's like
i mean they're dumb in that like just
don't say anything it'll go away what
did the pope
what are the didn't the pope just condem
he just case no gays no gays so you
drove it you did it
satan gonna make them a cake
satan's gonna make little nasdaq's okay
how about that how about that
um
so
now chet hanks
it's about to be a white boy summer i
mean
is he is he wrong
here's what i'll say for jedi what were
you gonna say no no my god chen hanks
could be the tom hanks of cameo if he
wanted to be
chet hanks could make a [ __ ] killing
on cameo
uh and a heck of a nose and a heck of a
jawline on that camera right he's he's a
nice symmetrical face and by the way
if you've asked who's celebrity what
celebrity kid it says i tom hanks
wouldn't be in my top 500. never colin
hanks on the other hand
is
is is what hey what's tom hanks like
um
so chet hayes it could be the time act
of cameo
chet hanks hayes he used to be called
chad hayes
um i think i believe he told the story
that he
took someone i know to prom who
chet hanks and showed up with another
girl
this guy he did you know he didn't say
that already this kid's been this kid's
been throwing strikes ah [ __ ] boys for a
while
that is
mean it wasn't me i don't i did she
explained to me it wasn't that mean
so
whatever he did who is this guy i don't
know i want to get into his business but
but this kid's been out this kid's been
wild
for at least
a dozen years
um now
if you're doing a
music festival
do you not book chet hanks as a reggae
artist
for the afternoon
3 45
like the walking dead just have him do
a half an hour of of reggae gibberish
uh
from 3 45 to 4 15. he's so bad on that
other stage
give me some what big up big up the
whole island massive it's a boy chattana
just do
model do jamaican
fake jafakin monologues if you can
jafakin monologues
put under put a beat underneath it
and give this kid
the the like the the bubble gum stage or
whatever
345 to 415. you can get them for 10
grand
i say
i say we do it
he's going a little way of kevin he's
like a charismatic kevin fetterline
kevin federline had no
well he said i don't i don't i don't i
have no idea what he said i had no idea
what he talked about hello
i don't know what that is his song nope
okay he was just like that douchey
what did what did we say at the one of
our
early days of this podcast rick
he's a he's a
racial identity
yes he's just real ricky
he's a real ricky
and that's funny because we're obviously
laughing at them but right at what point
do we hate them
you know what i mean um because it is
obviously funny because it's obnoxious
i i just the other thing i was like can
you imagine being tom hanks son
like the [ __ ] he's not doing better
colin because collins from
khan was born
he got like 10 years of tom hanks as a
normal person
what's the difference oh he's 43. he
looks good yeah colin's 43. so he's born
in 77. tom hanks doesn't pop really
until he's like same age as you
more or less yeah he's a he's we're
we're friends on twitter oh
look so sweet at one point
um
so if you're tom hanks his son never
mind you grew up in brentwood
like just
identity he's a rick i feel bad for i i
feel bad for a chat
not i feel
no i mean really why not like he's rich
like why what because
when you're a guy
and your dad is the biggest movie star
in the world like if john david
washington wasn't a big sir i believe
that he has other brothers yeah it's
just hard it's like charlie murphy or
vernon yeah there's a lot of weird
there's like it's a it's it's a it's
a little better your life's a little
better in some ways and a lot worse in
some ways
um so i being the rich
like what's his name michael douglas's
kid went to prison for 10 years
i don't it's you're rich and people
resent you and they no i get that you
can see how being
a celebrity kid can you can sink or swim
yeah or like just be regular yeah uh but
he
you know he like relishes in it he likes
it well now he's like a heel which is
why i'm saying let's book this kid
um heal hanks
um
when he came out with the juice
yo
pick up the youth then way out of
kingstown
and they wake up this morning let me see
the thing turn up
internet gone mad
respect you don't know
there's so far this is a really bad self
tape to get
imagine tom hanks watching this
imagine tom hanks having a conversation
with him
he he's
can you by the way the the girl i know
who went to the problem said he talked
in patchwork then no
um
so
but from tom hanks point of view you
must just be like
whoo
like you know i'm like about world war
ii right
like that's my thing i do like i'm an
american every man and i would just like
to say that
my son chet so
[ __ ]
i mean
pray for everybody he was on your honor
he was on the show i watched
he's the one he's the he's your honor no
he's he's he's he was just a
he's just a supporting character and
was
fine
yeah i you know acting
you know how i felt acting
no no i don't mean his the quali the
question he was a zombie
guy he looks like a zombie he got i
think he got fired this is one of those
this is a walking dead spin-off your
honor it's about a zombie judge
wow
this is a video game
this is the rest the last of us oh my
god okay
[Music]
now i sent you an article from the
washington post about
their that we're gonna have another
roaring 20s on our hands
rory
do you think
that's true
i
well one look at spring break in florida
yes most people were not in college
there was no opportunity to like pop
yeah go crazy yeah so
yeah but i don't know
i think it's not gonna be as i don't
think it'll pop up sweet i don't think
it'll be as culturally
defining
hopefully we will get another hitler at
the end
okay
another second hitler uh i don't but i
but this is my own bias i have no
[ __ ] idea by the way the person wrote
the article is no [ __ ] idea either no
no this is all just he needed to write
something yeah do you are sparkly
dresses coming back like it's like
right uh do you some people are getting
i've read a thing where some people are
getting anxiety that
things are opening up again because it
got really comfortable you're talking
we've talked about this like three weeks
ago like i'm don't like this
i liked my life but you i made two
commercials okay
one i make a gatorade and a chase
and
i sit and i'm a bad boy
and i do stand up like twice a month
does it
do you care what's going on outside
what do you mean
like who cares if it's open it's not
like you're going to participate really
i wouldn't mind
oh you're going to dinner
at a restaurant
in fact i did go to a dinner at a
restaurant
this past week at crossroads crossroads
i was going to say your beloved is open
yeah i have a
i [ __ ] up though cause i didn't study
the waitress's names on my placards oh
before i went in because i was like it's
been it's been a while yeah it's gone um
i
but i haven't gone and sat there i have
a i won from the store i won at like a
gift certificate of like a free meal at
crossroads and just kept every time we
saw it nothing greater than bringing in
a [ __ ] gift certificate even if you
paid top dollar for it you feel like a
little bit of a piece of [ __ ] well the
funny thing is i i actually got one once
and so i just called ahead i'm like i
know i had the person who gave it to us
a range i'm like i'm not gonna bring you
a piece of paper please don't make me do
that
um
but i just thought it would be so funny
if during the pandemic i was like uh
this
says i can
so no there's i'm here for what's mine
we're almost going out of business
that's not my problem my problem is i'm
hungry
and i have a gift certificate that says
you're gonna end that
um
yeah so
madonna
i saw it first of all i got i follow
like a lot of meme accounts on instagram
and there's way too many butts and stuff
like it's wait
like i'll be watching i'll be looking
i'll be scrolling it'll be like a girl
in a bikini i'm like dog i don't know
why why do they do the like random not
funny or associated to anything hot girl
because i think they they get paid they
must get yeah they get paid it seems
like an ad but yeah
and it's just a bummer
uh anyhow madonna posted one
madonna who was a singer in the 80s
and um
yeah 90s
ray light um
but that was the confession
um she posted a your titties are fat
she posted a a
thing
it's you know it's when you try hards
when you die hard
her boobs are great
i don't know i mean i her boot yes in a
vacuum
okay
those are like sheep madonna had the
best boob nipple ratio of my lifetime as
far as i'm concerned yeah i mean it's
great that one photo the one photo with
the hairy armpits from the 81. when
she's hitchhiking well that's later
madonna and the sex book the one in the
sex madonna was as hot a woman as
there's been
um
so
it's
super old her daughter by the way looks
like madonna
if she never
did never went to a beautician
and had didn't do her eyebrows didn't
dye her hair it's like what madonna but
the funny thing is she looks like
madonna until you see her dad
and then she looks exactly like her dad
yeah it's funny yes her dad used to live
in a building
that i lived in in new york
really yeah that guy's good looking he's
yeah good looking um
the
by the way not like a fame like just
a
walk like no doorman or anything like he
wasn't a rich guy
anyhow my friend eddie brill still lives
in the building it's where we used to
play poker long story
annie yeah i love it
um
that's a bit yeah so someone said what
is madonna
uh
some other
internet thing picked it up and was like
what's banana uh serving and i said
butterscotch candies from the bottom of
her purse did you write that i did
it didn't get that many likes
by the way got like 20 likes
which was like that's pretty good joke
um
i had a hot i had a hot comment
yesterday by the way you can pick up
followers with comments just putting
funny comments on other people's [ __ ]
yeah it always shocks me something like
that i would never follow somebody
because they made a funny comment you
see what i wrote then you go who the
[ __ ] is this oh and then you're like
hey that's not bad
predictable um
so anyhow um
madonna oh blake our friend blake dunked
in a game that's good he hadn't he he uh
cause any of uh
he
he dunked
i still
i don't think he's going to pick up
because he's brand new now
um
he's going to be brand new he's going to
be brand new you know how he is
he does he he big times us and he gives
us five thousand dollars
[Music]
yeah he ain't picking up he would have
picked up by now
should we leave a message
no
you can't leave a message on facetime
you should be able to just leave a
aggressive video
i have an android i wouldn't pick it up
he's he's brand new he's in new york now
he doesn't he don't know nobody he's in
new york yeah i got traded to to the
nets i have a question explain to me
basketball stuff so what were all these
memes because it was like the dream team
and then they're like because basically
the nets
like the nets got the nets had
kyrie irving and kevin durant two of the
top five still top ten and then they got
james harden who's like the best okay
and then so they had those three
and then they got blake
okay who is a
you know one of them
it's like uh
he wasn't he's a multi-time all-star
like a generation you know great [ __ ]
player and then
then they got another guy
uh
they got lamarcus aldridge so like
another guy like they they're all
they're all like
blake and lamarcus are
not are out probably out of who [ __ ]
knows but
but like they've had injuries whereas
those three guys are like peaking and
needs five
those are all same as five yeah the game
is blake and lamarcus will come off the
bench
and they're like all like it's it's a is
it a big deal
ah
i mean it's like it's a thing people can
complain about complain or be like oh
this is well blake made a good point
which is like everyone said i sucked
right and then i got on the nets and
you're like this is not fair like well i
thought
that's where you see the thing say what
you want about blake very petty person
i love it the core of our relationship
it's based on a shared pettiness did you
see what he said when he dunked
i still got it no i'll play it
to play griffin as he stares down the
pistons [ __ ]
[Applause]
he's saying it like i knew him
but you guys didn't think i had i
that's like the mighty
if he picked up if he because he's a
coward he didn't pick up
um
but i was gonna say was it was where did
you feel like you were flying again
um
but he's a it's he's a good he's a good
guy and uh and i'm happy and the funny
thing was somebody
texted me and asked if
blake needed a sublet in new york
oh wow and i had to write back he makes
45 million dollars a year
do you think he's gonna sublet an
apartment in brooklyn
your friend with the walk up with no
doorman i mean kind of
um
well i don't know what this was what
millennials don't like boobs
and paul kids what career well which
hold on
so the kids so they polled kids which
careers they want and
okay so um
they did a survey
and uh
in the us and uk
now the number one um
career aspirations for kid is uh youtube
or a vlogger
it feels like are we
what are we doing where we're just it's
our obsolescence
we're building our own
the thing that will undo us all that's
what we're doing we're just building the
contraptions by which
we're hoisting ourselves up by our own
patard isn't is my old man oh my god
hoisted
by his own fatality okay put [ __ ]
look that up
lou
hoisted no hoisted by his own pitard
there it is
hoist with his own potara that may be
the oldest man phrase i've ever old man
it comes with a photo of old man old
english
drawing
the meaning is literally that a bomb
maker is blown up
always funny
off the ground by his own bomb a battard
is a small
uh explosive device
you've been hoisted ladies and gentlemen
you've been hoisted
um uh yeah so like oh more than a third
of the kids surveyed wanted to be a
vlogger or youtuber
i remember in high school
part of the crew the drinking the
preschool kid crew um the preschool crew
uh
i remember arguing with one of the guys
in it and going like you don't want to
be famous
and he was like no
i was like not at all
and he's like not even a little bit
i always felt
like again this is so i can't even judge
these kids
i always felt like
i had a camera crew following me even
though i didn't have a cramp i was like
that was kind of my pov yeah was like
i'm a kid in high school and like this
is the video about me it's a maniac's
point of view and the only and then the
next person i ever met who had that
point of view
was dave chappelle that's so funny i
remember going like did you ever feel
like and he's like yeah absolutely
he called it we ended up calling it the
unseen audience
that's good like doing [ __ ] could you do
a sketch that's a funny well
it's doing [ __ ] for
it's if you're ever it's like if
somebody it's just like hammering
you're not even hamming it up it's a
documentary about you oh okay
so the unseen audience is like
you
say something funny to a guy at a
drugstore that no one no yeah your
audience will get it
they don't exist
but it's the right they'll appreciate it
right even though they're never going to
see it that's and no one has any idea
what you're talking about that's very
good i think it's a i assume it's a
forming art it's like a
something
[Music]
it's i'm sure it's a on the tree of
narcissism it's a symptom
it's a symptom of narcissism but it was
fun so i can't judge these kids why
wouldn't you want to be an influencer
why what was your
youtuber back when you were in high
school
like mpv just
that's really fun
they were like you know john norris
kennedy kennedy john norris uh adam
something with the hair sujan pak
sujan pak was like late susan park was
like what about ananda ananda ananda
someone shouted out on honda the other
day on she's hot
was she considered
she didn't do it for me
but
i know i know what you mean who was the
weird guy who's the weirdest
matt pinfield
these are all the late 90s people of
course who was the crazy guy
his hair was always out uh the guy that
they found on a on a uh
uh they found him in a contest
oh [ __ ] he had one name i believe yeah
it was one name it was like kennedy but
it was uh uh [ __ ] what was his name they
found him and he was like kind of
homeless no not cadoos not please
don't we're not bringing cadoos in here
not tyrese not caduce
i used to do a joke about this it was
like
[Music]
jessie
jesse something oh
yeah jesse it was jesse
jesse cam jesse camp
yes that was yeah that was that was it
but i thought i was thinking bigger with
the name there he is he's gotten better
looking yeah
no
he had me and then he lost me he was
cute and then he got on meth now he
looks like me no is that him
tommy
me and tommy lee or as i like to call it
tommy me
now guys they come up with puns
the machine once i turn the machine on
in the morning guys it's going to come
up with puns and there's nothing we can
do about it
um
apparently
boobs are not
dems are not
popular they don't like them they're not
as popular butts are more popular click
on them click on that click on the
click on embrace
pretty depressing study what's the
matter this is from three years ago
no no there was one that came i like
read the article that was
breast related searches
only make 1.5 percent of all certainty
well that's okay wait wait wait wait
wait wait explain it
you could only search
when it started there was
boobs okay and butts
okay those were the categories okay now
there's
75 like what do you want to do to the
boobs okay
how big do you want the there's so many
sub categories i just like do you want
to smack it
do you want a dick whatever there's so
many categories that that's you i can't
okay
now am i going i'm just like am i
obsolete
i'm not no you got a couple years left
oh um rude now
here's my question okay
that is an argument i've had with jamila
jamil a number of times which is
is because she claims a lot of her
friends like short guys which i'm like
no i don't think that's true i don't
like you um
how much of this is conditioning
i think most of it
because i think most of it is
conditioning why i mean think about it
back in the day people would be
commenting on a woman's ankles like you
got some nice ankles girls show them off
because that was all i could show
right but it is conditioning i'm just
saying so and now that you can show a
lot more who gives a [ __ ] about an ankle
uh you're misunderstanding what i'm
saying is
if you
were you
propagandized into liking tall guys
i don't i say that about you and most
women
i think it's evolutionary you want a
tall guy because you're you're afraid of
threats okay you want a guy with broad
shoulders you want to have a big
forehead i don't think that there's any
men like women big breasts i mean it's a
joke i used to do but it's like they we
literally think they'll be able to feed
a baby better sure but if we don't
compare it with men if we just keep it
to women and what
is
the body parts that are you know
popular why take it out of men it's my
point because i think there's enough
examples of women
looking at a big butt doesn't tell you
like
like what she takes giant shits i mean
it's like that's something else we're
conditioning ourselves that's what i
like
okay uh i'm just saying i get
my pipes you know what i mean keep going
i get boobs i get the like hip to waist
ratio thing but ankles okay but i don't
no one the ankles thing is like
when they're covered head to toe what
i'm saying is
i like like the hot one of the hottest
women ever to me
is
linda carter as wonder woman now
it was in syndication
when i'm starting to think
some different things about women
81
82
but also she's a [ __ ]
box to me okay right
and then you get into freudian stuff
my mom's got dark hair like [ __ ] like
that like
i don't know i'm irish like that's kind
she's part irish there's [ __ ] like
that just works
on me without conditioning now if i
hadn't seen her star as wonder woman
would i
think she was a fox
i don't know i tend to think i would
because i was offered charlie's angels
at the same time
and i everyone's got a boy band everyone
picks their
guy
i just think you like what you like
and i don't i i don't
believe it's much conditioning because
because i've been around
i've been around black dudes for 20
years who
it's that's a very butt-centric thing
yeah but it never that's
not that's less as a white guy it's just
less butt centric it's grown more butt
centric over time right
but this is what my point was that like
ankles or anything else that comes
there's some things that just stay
in vogue so like boobs
in the 50s and 60s when people were
talking about ankles and calves and [ __ ]
the skirts it wasn't covered head-to-toe
i mean they had giant plates i missed
the ankle you missed it but i'm just
talking about historically right so
they were still like tight clothing on
them and maybe they were covered but
there was a lot to look at right like
they had that kind of like more pokey
boob shape that we don't really have
anymore stuff like that the figure yeah
he's got a nice figure exactly so
butts
were not in they were not super popular
let's just say amongst the majority
white people in the 80s and they are
really popular by like butts
butts that's what i'm saying so butts
weren't popular in the 80s when you
could see a lot of skin on women you
know what i mean so i think now it's a
little it just feels like a conditioning
it feels like
we see
kardashians yeah kardashian so the ideal
body type has changed so i think there's
some things that you said like you said
that are just in you and you can't
really change that and i think there's
some things that go with the times
and
i don't know i like butts is a good
example
yeah it's not like we were
covered head to toe what i will say
though is i don't get
i think it you'd be hard-pressed to get
me
physically like
what will give you an erection i don't
think you can sell through
i can't
because the
because the the um
cultures become more butt-centric right
i don't think you can hack my
nervous system or whatever is
responsible for boners
the boner department um
more boobs or butt
i've i've boobs all day i've been boobs
but bim boobs i it's more figures i'm
actually a big skin guy yeah you don't
know me i'm a skinny guy
uh i like my skin is like whoosh like
that's one of those things where i'm
like this is nothing like a man's skin
um you just you just want it to be so
opposite you know what's funny about
linda carter too
alcoholic
not as healthy as you thought not as
healthy as i thought but also was i
attracted to that could i sense it at
the age of eight or nine
that i not like i've dated a lot of
alcoholic women's women's my dad was
um right is there some things
but she's like gal gadot it's more or
less the same figure i do wonder what
i think everything with attraction is
three parts like your environment that
you grew up in
uh
what you just actually like
and then what likes you i for guys
it's ninety percent the last what likes
you it's we don't get you just go oh i
keep getting this i wonder if there's a
guy well that's my it looks like we got
a type voice do you think
that there's a guy out there that gets a
certain type that
actually really wants another type i'm
positive there is
i'm positive a guy wrote a note and then
wrote a letter today that's like
i don't i i'm i
he wants what he he's getting older and
less attractive
but he still is attracted to its guys
are like that's where the like the fat
guy of like
raiding women like the grossest dude in
the world raiding women on the internet
it's like guys never
go you know what maybe i should
moderate because again you have to hack
your nervous system
into being attracted to this other thing
but guys absolutely
get our type assigned to us
and then
do you think
i mean are they just dissatisfied or
they don't think about it
i bet they're dissatisfied
and that's they go to process are they
sex work they just have a secret life
of their of that thing they really like
are you do you get the type that you're
attracted to
yeah i'm lucky but i can tell you
the
psychographic of the kind of woman who
likes me a lot like often
i and i told this to a woman and she was
like [ __ ] you're exactly right what
it's a girl
woman
who is
pretty well educated
this is who like who likes this is the
kind of girl who likes me routinely
pretty well educated
uh and
media interested
maybe works in media maybe but is like
interested and um
i'm like
i'm a bad boy to her oh you're like the
right i'm a bad boy cause like i'm
yeah i'm literate i'm you know erudite
well-read all that [ __ ]
but i know a lot of black dudes
i'm like james dean listen to hip-hop
credibly right like a little something
it's not actual but it is if you're that
kind of woman
like
is that what you're attracted to or is
that just what you get
we're talking about internal okay so uh
it's both it's all the and a lot of
times they have dark hair
that's funny and they're
generally in good shape
and they're all attractive like they're
not i showed you a bunch of yeah they're
like they're all pretty attractive and
they're all
this same level of attraction yeah
yep it's funny yeah it's really funny i
can like look at a girl i'm like that's
a deal i ca by the way i can look at a
girl and be like she would like me
not even like funny how i bet there's
something to that because i know if i i
know a type of guy that would like me i
can't like categorize it how you can
yeah um but it's just like a
spark it's just like that guy would be
attracted to me
there i was dating a girl one time who
was like you know i went to harvard and
i was like i didn't know that but i'm
not surprised like it's not i'm not like
oh yeah no neil um please the uh
harvard schmarvart
um
but
yeah like so you can kind of tell
it's not even about me it's it there's
also those things of like if they put a
bunch of people in a room
if they put 10 men and 10 women
that if you like numerically one through
10 in terms of looks tens get with tens
eights get eights
two scope of twos
like and that's that has to do with like
it's elimination it's [ __ ] up when we
when it's a good looking guy and a not
so good looking girl we cannot process
it
as human beings
pierce brosnan
but pierce brosnan's wife is age
appropriate looking people are like what
the [ __ ] or they're like they're
hero
um
like this guy's a hero yeah they look
perfect together yeah actually they they
are all i guess she gained she just
gained some weight but yeah people use
her like 70. people use her as ugly
spouse
uh there's one i'm thinking of that i
don't want to say because i think it's
pretty cool it's all rude it's
what i said was rude but that's kind of
what i meant
i'm a bad boy um
but
i also
when i look at that it does dance on my
brain i'm like
how wide i think that it dances on your
brain it does i'm like how why what how
does that work like with it yeah we're
just what do they usually
does he make her eat outside
you know who actually
has this issue i
i know if you guys who
black men
who get
white women way more but actually really
want to date a black woman yeah
they just tell the black woman
please help me they they pretend oh i
want these oh i wish these white girls
oh
one i saw this one called the bell of
versailles 73 and it's really it
actually is
so [ __ ] amazing they should make a
movie about it but basically um in the
70s and before that the fashion houses
america was seen as like not a serious
fashion house it was all about the
european ones
so they brokered a deal that
uh they were going to have like a re
like an american presentation of their
types of fashion so they brought like
all the
hottest peop the hottest fashion
designers but they had to do it quick
and they didn't have a budget so they
ended up hiring a lot of lower end
models
black models which were cheaper and then
lower in white my white models
and
they go to it's just so interesting all
the like race relations and dealing with
europeans in the 70s and they're rude i
feel like i've heard about this like
somewhere else anyways really good that
one was good that's just good watch it
if it's not the greatest documentary
documentary wise but the story is so
good you forget yeah it's great um
did you see see spiricy
no i didn't watch it yet
i don't know what i was doing this week
we should let's just we'll save it well
let's just save it but basically
i'm like okay you know what it's on the
level of
what the hell black fishy
type where
i've been it's we're 10 years from
collapse i mean this is one of these
things where i i'm vegan and people
[ __ ]
okay
if you like seafood i don't like seafood
if you don't but i also am
it's like
collapse of the en of a whole thing a
part of the earth of the ecosystem
done
yes and but the interesting thing is one
the guy you know i hate to hate on my
fellow persian but
i don't like when people
try to make their documentary about them
a little
and then abandon it just stay the whole
time or what did he
quit
like at first
or the you know the one where the
the guy like what the hell like like he
calls the 1-800 number like yeah did you
know and they're like um let me
grant
that's bad documents that's bad
filmmaking it's hacky filmmaking it's
hacky it's like
you're this is just like a setup and
then
he did that to a few people like they
would not
sit down for an interview so you just
showed up to their headquarters and
accosted they're afraid
yeah so that was annoying but
it goes places i did not realize the
amount of slavery oh that's good that
yeah
is behind
yeah a lot of fishing you ain't getting
off you're a thousand miles from the
nearest person you complain to and it's
a it's a 12 years as a slave slavery
it's like to have drinks yeah tomorrow
we leave okay yeah cool i'm gonna make
some money cool cool cool and then you
can't get off the boat
they will kill you some people jump to
their death they can't get off the boat
it's just free labor yeah
then now that's in our that's that's
asian hate honestly i'm not even kidding
that's real asian hate it like again not
to belittle
the american violence but i'm saying
it's that's so funny i think that's
largely
thailand filipino the thai saudis my
thai people man
it
is and i didn't realize the
i like this somali pirates now
they used to scare me what what do you
like about them um
it's obviously you're the captain out
but guys yeah hello classic lions um
because
europe overfished their waters they
started coming into africa and
overfishing their then kick the somali
pirates are just fishermen that are
getting um pushed out at their own
industry you wouldn't tell to look at
their bodies they look pretty well
nourished
maybe i'm wrong on this maybe i haven't
seen enough of them but they
they all seem pretty healthy watch it
and then we can uh yeah i know i intend
to i'm surprised you didn't you watched
it
i don't know what the [ __ ] i had a bunch
of spots and then i got my own
documentaries to worry about
[Music]
hey neil and that beautiful model always
sitting next to you
from africa here in a country called
kenya
time recently since joining
i've been hearing you on a couple of
episodes trashing africa
and uh i just wanted you to know that we
do listen yep
yeah
this is not you doing ayahuasca neo we
do listen and uh you guys fighting dirk
i don't have to take any of these [ __ ]
real african about this
love the show love you guys and uh
i don't have to take this
let's go feels
and you just bashed africans
well
it was that was a i did that
intentionally
to make him look good pre-schooling some
of my close friends are africans
not african-americans real africans
trevor noah of course
we all know do you know david
david kabuka
no
people don't know what david kabuki
daniel kahlua you sure do
do you know uh joseph opio one of the
funniest people i've ever met did kabuka
and opio both write for trevor
opio
is
uh
one of the weirdest people i've ever met
and it's so good he's never gotten a
cold because he does not believe in them
and he's 38.
and he's like he looks he's like he
looks like a smiley pirate and that he's
so [ __ ] skinny
like wears wind it's he's [ __ ]
hilarious okay um when you see him you
go oh he you're right
um
and he's a very funny person will not
make me
will not allow me to make a documentary
about him i was like wakes up in the
middle of the night
just so he can appreciate how good his
sleep has been
this is a guy who does not think like a
normal person
and he's great he's one of the great
africans
um
africa thank you for listening and uh
you know that we it's you're you know
how you know how i feel about africa
i don't really do i have a i like it i
don't know would you go
they gotta work on their resorts a
little bit they have great resorts what
are you talking about they have a four
seasons yeah they have mozambique they
have like seven star resorts seven
not even i don't but i'm not a i gotta
figure out because i'm not a new
mozambique dude
are there four seasons in africa
oh they're i no not got it tanzania
that's uh that's africa can you go best
beaches mozambique i need you to see
this
look how all different
it's all look look at that
yeah i should go it's far i know that i
know that if you fly to thailand you can
fly to mozambique that's a lot further
right there it is
i'm just kind of it is
also people don't realize because our
maps are racist how much bigger africa
is
oh it's africa's so big you can't
believe it's gigantic so um
like when trevor flies from south africa
to america
from
like
paris to
america is the short part
he's got to fight 24 hours from
joe
it's like
it's a lot i also got to say for africa
it's a bit how i fee the thing i say
when i do black shows when i do black
stand-up shows which is i know you guys
come here to get away from white people
oh so you don't want to be like hey you
surprised you guys but if they want to
be a taurus i'll be a tourist could be a
tourist i mean obviously black people i
heavily
enjoy
i mean enjoys the wrong horse but you
know have have some of my deepest most
my most meaningful relationships
it's my favorite
you've got mail i'm bianca this is going
to be a long ass letter so i decided to
read it now it's a long ass voice memo
feel free to cut me off when
all right
i was happily surprised by last week's
ep where neil mentioned the aromantic
subreddit
i joined reddit last year because i've
been questioning my sexuality and i
wanted an anonymous place to explore the
alphabet communities
thank you for giving the arrow community
a shout out and some friendly exposure
my only bone to pick is the clear-cut
ridicule you both gave to the term
alloromantic which suggested you may be
misunderstanding what the word actually
means
as you said on the pod an alloromantic
is someone who experiences romantic
attraction
after seeing this definition you mocked
these people putting a whiny voice to
your perceived narrative of their
mindset
[ __ ] useless terms because
everyone else i need a term that's
they're the norms i stand by it
neil bianca hate to break it to you but
you're allo romantics you're allosexuals
you don't need to make fun of these
people they're you
aloe romantic
new
okay
a question i actually am confused right
now because it says uh someone who
experiences romantic attraction it is
possible to be allo romantic but not
allosexual my brain
you experience
romantic attraction
uh
allosexual means sexual just like allah
romantic means romantic
allosexual means sexual without romance
alloromantic means
yes
yes
aloe romantic sorry allosexual
i don't i stand by the original point
miss thank you for listening wild people
i don't believe you need a term for
the majority or the norm
most people are
the culture is romantic the the culture
is romantic and sexual if you're not
that then yeah get a term i don't it's
why i use the word sis because i
i used it to ridicule in tandem because
i kind of believe
when comedy rules apply
over
70 80 90 that's the norm that's
cisgender is like yeah i'm the gender
that my genitalia said
that's most people yeah so you don't
it's like people don't say hi
you don't say i'm righty you just if
you're lefty you say something if you're
writing we just assume you're ready
doors are set up that way it's like
it's like it's the analogy i made
blake's seven whatever the [ __ ] he is
and he has to do this he has to bend his
neck under doors which i never thought
about
so what i'm saying is
well i don't think we offended her i
think she was
she sounded a little annoyed but yeah
but i
annoyings fine
um
uh i don't i'm of the mind that you
don't need a term for the majority
and then i did say i took a
psych class in college and they label
everything things that don't necessarily
need a label right and
i felt my impression was
like
white people problems not really but
just why are we over complicating
the fact that
at night
it's a black pla like it you think it's
a guy doing this but it's actually a
black plastic bag rolling there's like
oh
for that there was like a term for that
you know that my the teacher was
explaining
i don't know
maybe it's just
i think different industries like a lot
of terms to be perfectly honest
uh but there's also that thing of like
the germans have a lot it might just be
like age of society yeah maybe or french
people have a lot of it's like the word
of the staircase the germans have a lot
of
cool words
so calm down put it they all have
sunglasses on they all go la da da da da
and the sunglasses come down on words
egg life um
goodbye you've got mail hey neil and
bianca
um i'm a pretty sociable person and i
have gotten to know the staff at a local
bar extremely well i text some of the
female bartenders and know the male
bouncers less managers
problem is
now that i know the head bouncer manager
really well i kind of get the suspicious
vibe he has towards the female
bartenders like
inappropriate comments or sexualizing
instagram girls will pull up on his
phone in front of me in front of the
bartenders
he does have three daughters and tries
to be professional as well but i get
these moments with him that are red
flags a few of the bartenders i know
there have been fired quit or have gone
off to the bars
and the owner of the bar is a woman who
owns a few of the bars and restaurants
in this area in orange county but when
it comes to the
day-to-day operations she really trusts
him to kind of handle it i've met her
once or twice and she seems very
professional i guess my question is is
it on me to ask or say anything i'm a
black guy with mostly white friends who
i'd expect to stand up and or say
something do something when it comes to
like racism and would be disappointed if
they didn't
but as a male in the situation i'm
conflicted or maybe looking to dodge
responsibility because i don't believe
that i'm the male that has come to save
them especially since they have a female
owner
and i've never been or had a service
industry job
um or been in bartending
i'm not sure what's your level of
comfort
um
racism is interesting
in that i don't
if you don't work there you can't say
[ __ ]
oh yeah in this case like if you don't
work there you can't say [ __ ]
now
the thing i was saying earlier about
having to fight people
i
during all the george floyd stuff the
first george floyd stuff the the
original before the trial now we're in
the trial it's
cr i said to somebody america's like a
town where there's just a [ __ ]
horrible carnival every week like
there's a new horrible carnival come to
town we're like what is it well they
murdered a black fella for no reason now
we're gonna have a trial on television
it's a wait is this related to the
colorado nope
the
i did say some [ __ ] to people during
george floyd i two guys
and
one of them i thought i might have to
fight really yeah what were they saying
i
they were they were they were
he came at me with fight energy it was
over text he came at me with fight
energy and i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna
have to fight this guy now
and
it's a weird not like i wouldn't say
anything i say [ __ ] about race fairly
often and i've also said [ __ ] in like i
was doing a pilot one time and there was
a writer on the show who was just had
real weird energy with women and i was
like dog you either need to not speak to
women on staff
or
change your entire thing
and
like i said like you this it's bad yeah
i and i don't want to get
like it's wrong in and of itself but
also it's a really bad reflection of me
because i wanted you to work on it
um
so i will say in a work situation i
think you're entitled to say pretty much
more or less anything
then you're into power dynamics and all
that [ __ ] but
but i can't you can't go to somebody
else's job be like i'm calling sexism
yeah and because
you might know the balance a little bit
you don't know him like that
no it's true i mean anytime you step in
um
like yeah just
yeah go
on your business playboy it feels a
little
like one time someone and it's not an at
all the same but somebody
a
a comic tried to tell me that i wasn't
doing my job right didn't didn't turn
out i didn't like it
no just it was he was one he was wrong
he he said i was not doing my job and i
walked some customers
and i was like
do you don't want to go down this route
you have no idea what you're talking
about and made a stink
told the manager
and looked
foolish
yeah and it was very great so and the
manager was like nah this is not your
concern you can talk to me separately no
imagine a customer doing it
yeah a customer well a customer well no
like it get like you know what who's
who's the man like i know the manager
i'm here a lot because it's not that
it's giving it to them yeah i could
stream to them but i actually saw that
happen i'll tell you afterwards it
happened
a comic yelled
at
one of the bartenders for treating the
other bartender terribly and speaking to
her terribly and
nothing happened everyone still is in
the same industry
if someone who work i'm saying people
that work together can
can talk about stuff because there's a
governing body it's like it's there's
already a cop there the job is
but i think in our life like a com like
the comics can't really get involved
with a
waitress beef you know what i mean like
that's a little overstepping your
boundaries but if you see someone being
shitty to another person you don't think
it's weird for you to step up i if i saw
somebody
talking down to you i think or not even
you or there's probably five or six
wages that i know
enough to be like yo the [ __ ] you don't
okay yeah that makes sense so you think
just a straight customer but aren't is
it a local at a bar i feel like a local
local at a bar
starts it starts getting a little uh
yeah until they until
uh yeah so what do you so what does he
do just
nothing
there's nothing you can do sexism i mean
like sexism pictures instagram
i don't know i mean you could
like they should maybe i feel like the
waitress is a bartender should say
something or a bouncer should say
something or somebody works there but
you can't be like
excuse me manager of a restaurant i go
to can i speak to you you know morally
he's not it's not illegal it's also not
going to do anything you could if you
were going to sell it you could be like
you might want to be careful with those
pictures because i don't know if you
read the paper like that's not
it's not going well for guys who show
pictures of women at work
bianca has been to sri lanka
swinging a mess
i i actually got to say i like i was
turning on it only because i felt
bianca's turning on an energy but i
liked it what no
i'm a state legislator well you're in
trouble because he's a state legislator
currently working on preventing ending
police brutality i was listening to your
recent episode discussing the george
floyd settlement i wanted to clarify
something the payouts for police
brutality in most states counties
municipalities don't do a damn thing to
help fix our wildly broken system why
one the cops aren't liable because of a
horrible little thing called qualified
immunity
uh until recently most people have never
heard of it but oh my it's a doozy and
one of the best tools around to protect
corrupt cops two the community in
question that's already suffering from
police brutality and it's rarely if ever
a one-off sort of thing gets punished
again by being forced to take money away
from other important local services in
order to pay for the horrific behavior
of the cop oh yeah so they got to pay
out of there
settle they have to settle the poor
neighborhood asked to
take tax revenue and give it to the cops
[ __ ] uh i would love to hear your
thoughts on qi i think more people need
to know about it and you two do an
amazing job break things down even if
those things are horrifying racist
policies to protect corrupt cops bless
up homies bless up didn't really take
off the way we hoped
and thanks for your humor and insight
uh we talked about we talked about a lot
we didn't know what it was called one
week but then the next week yeah and
then we talked about the
like municipal insurance that they have
and we did the whole thing but
i mean
there's no
if you got rid of it
would you sign up to be a cop cause a
cop's
a designated [ __ ] in most people's
eyes like here comes a cop like
everything's anti-cop i mean i know we
see like flags and [ __ ] but no those
people are that until they're dramatic i
think
i i don't know how you middle class
upper middle class and above i think
cops are generally pretty well they get
but those people will flip on a dime the
moment a cop treats them like they're
poor well how dare they
i pay your bills
um so i'm wondering
how to get rid of it
i would if i was a cop i would not be a
cop without some sort of protection
you know because if i have to put my
hands on you everyone always feels
violated by cops why are you questioning
me i don't need to do that i don't need
to [ __ ] off
again i
say what you want it's a [ __ ] bad job
even if you think it's
they're absolute terrorist pieces of
[ __ ]
it's not a good job right because we
forget about when i see a i live in
korea town so i see this a lot but
a screaming person with like untreated
mental health but that's being high
that's being victimized all the cops
that's what they're doing i wouldn't be
like
bring a gentle like healthcare like oh
my god this person's throwing i was in a
i was in a coffee shop and a guy
i was sitting outside and i told my
friend like let's go inside she's like
why huh like get the [ __ ] inside yeah as
soon as we get inside he picks up a like
a leftover glass someone hadn't bust
throws it at the glass that's protecting
us
it was the most white liberal [ __ ] i've
ever he comes i'm like i i'm like don't
open the door yeah and the the manager's
like
see come on in sir i'm like dude he's in
he's in he's on drugs get him out of
here
this guy's trying to talk to me like
what what do you need what do you need
from us he's like i want water
so he's like okay give him a glass of
water exactly like the glass he just
threw at he takes the water and throws
it glass explodes everywhere on people
and so
i was like get into the [ __ ] out yeah
and then uh a band of like five
screenwriters i'm assuming sure uh
checkered collared charts yes
laptops uh apple macbooks got it
banded together and like just literally
banded like surrounded and like you
gotta go and they
scooted him out okay we're gonna come on
no you gotta go dude come on dude
and i'm like why did you do that i
understand you don't wanna be on the
wrong side of things but this guy was
putting all of us in danger because you
were playing what do you say like
liberal jenga
yeah basically they were i mean that's
not even jenga they're they're not
worried about anything they i guess they
were worried about being canceled for
not letting in a homeless i'm like
excuse me it's not the time
we're
all in we're all hell we're all held
hostage so uh the
cops as i said
you say in the champs all the time they
are human garbagemen
they are in charge of picking up
the any situation is their
responsibility i know it's like
when people just put a couch on the
sidewalk it's the human equivalent of
that come get this cat what do you mean
this cat i don't i don't want it but
it's because we use cops as a like i
would that guy needed
that guy needed a healthcare worker and
some muscle
muscle and her healthcare worker you
know but the only thing we all know how
to do is like call the cops this guy's
[ __ ] scaring everyone and putting
everyone in physical scenes now what
liberals are gonna have to deal with is
when
they're gonna have to worry about
litigation for sending the wrong crew
well yeah so let's say they send the car
they sent but let's say they send
the healthcare worker and the guy starts
stabbing people
yeah what's the crime of intimacy
uh then
but then if they send the cop let's say
we call the cops and then that guy was
violent he was violent to everybody any
they shot him dead i would be like why
did you do that of course you're right
the i that's it just goes my point of
the police problem is an incredibly hard
problem we use we overuse police we
overuse police but
and we and guess what we're going to
underuse them and then we're go and we
don't know what when to do what we need
like a group of unarmed bouncers
we know there there's plenty i think
what you're talking about maybe we'll
put them on motorcycles call them hell's
angels i think how this could work
um you've got this hey i wanted to talk
about my jeremy piven hit the goods come
on
um i don't really have many stories
about it but which one are you do i have
an old one no it's on the back of page
one hey i'm a big fan of the show
kkk yeah then at the end he says
oh that show should be whatever kkk
rally
i never knew you directed the goods well
i did
and um he wanted stories
oh oh you got it
here's a funny story that's more weird
than it's not even weird i think you
told it but go ahead it's a different
story
there's a scene where we're doing a long
jeremy has if we're in a minivan
and jeremy's got a long monologue
and but i was getting a wide
and
ving
ving rave's like
uh neil brother
um do you think uh you don't need me for
this i'm like ving you're in the shop
and he was like
i mean yeah but you don't really need me
he was trying to trick me into thinking
i didn't need him
because he in the scene he was asleep
so he had tricked himself into thinking
well if i'm asleep
like this i don't need to be here or
nobody
nobody
and it's a shot it's a frontal shot it's
like the wide
so then i started i did a thing that i
wish we'd done where i was like actually
you know what
because when you do a
scene driving scene you do it once then
you have to go back to where you started
so that it matches the backgrounds match
the background matches so you're saying
roughly the same words in the same
locations
so we would have to drive back to the
place and while we're driving back i go
you know while we're all driving back
why don't we all
take a shot at jeremy's monologue real
quick let's just one at a time everyone
do the monologue how you would do it
which would have been did he get it yeah
he was like he thinks the whole thing is
like you don't need me
um
and again
a huge gossip and you knew it was going
to be great when you say can i tell you
something
um
and i used to do a joke with him that he
took the greatest rape of all time on
camera i mean took it
that's like every the most homophobic
guy in the world biggest gangster in the
world be like
he took it like a g
and talking about pulp fiction yeah of
course but
yeah i a lot of people would not have
wouldn't have done it
it's such a good part though
such a good part in other scenes and
it's a [ __ ] crazy great moment it's a
crazy game i did it did like kind of
make me like oh man this is rough
oh it was that whole movie was like wow
man rape
yeah
but it's so good
it's an unbelievable it's like top 10 of
all time so is it worth being in one of
the greatest movies all time if you're
well that's what i'm saying it's
the most digni i mean it's like street
code
he like hit all the
he hit all the he was the
gangster villain for the first half of
the movie yeah like a bad shot from
behind like mythology
and then
the a
hilarious reversal
i mean hilariously great reversals
you don't need me you're right brother
you don't need him here
quentin you don't need me in this
in this [ __ ] box
brother goodbye you've got mail dear
neil
dear bill winks and nil
nil a little much um just woke up from a
dream where i ran into nail on the
street and didn't say anything but then
i thought what when am i gonna get the
chance to say hi to neil again so i turn
around and give him an ad a boy he just
stared at me said no
and then walked out of salt and straw
without ordering anything
the first part i believed the second
part i would never you would never walk
never
am i listening to too much podcast or
spirit padre gotten into astral
projection have any fans uh ever
bought or sent you ice cream and wasn't
vanilla like you wanted or were you
disappointed and by how much
uh also
neil what was the book that helped you
make smoking gross for yourself and
maybe there's an alcohol one was it alan
cars
i didn't read a book
i uh hypnotism no i mean i didn't not to
stop smoking i just decided
and by the way didn't
uh not be too graphic didn't have a
bowel movement for i believe six days
and uh after not smoking after not
smoking and i believe uh
dave chappelle videotaped me on the way
to the house on the sixth day
uh in 1998 i believe was the year
um
so yeah i don't but but
uh maybe we cut that letter goodbye
you've got hey kneeling bianca lstner
neil you've been talked in recent you've
talked in recent episodes about dating
multiple asian women and might have
eluded
alluded uh to being seen publicly as
possibly fetishizing them i'm white my
girlfriend's black and
four years before her i also dated
another black woman i casually dated
other women in between but going back to
back serious relationships with black
women definitely has me judged by
acquaintances none of my real friends
care and i don't plan to do anything
about it
but my questions are have you ever
received serious flack for dating
multiple women of the same race and uh
is there anything a person can do to
remove the stigma from interracial
dating
i have a theory go
you're damned if you do damn if you
don't if you
especially if you've dated a black woman
before
then she's like oh so i'm your fetish
and if you never dated a black woman
she'll be like
well i don't want to train you
so there's no there is no winning
there's a i think you can pick up you
can pick up if someone
is just
in like there's a difference between
being into thai and being into a type
and having a fetish
fetish is
any i don't give a [ __ ] black skin
check you know
i know people who have fetishes not
necessarily against black women but
black men
who are white
uh and it's a first time hair of it
other than a giant category are usually
scandinavian just joking uh but they're
really but they are but but seriously
there it was one one of them posted the
words the caption god's gift to women
and it was a photo of
a very like sickly looking wiz khalifa
and i was like i love i love stuff like
that
listen i
wuz khalifa is not a bad looking guy it
was just
yeah
it's like you're you're
but i don't know i mean this is where
you get bringing politics into it to me
is a little unfair because politics
well yeah racial politics yeah um is a
little unfair because
i i don't know man doesn't it just some
feel
i think it's just doesn't some [ __ ] just
feel fetishy and so right but if a
girl's dated
uh a bunch of guys that kind of look
like me is that a fetish or is that just
this is their type
right
when does it become a fetish is it like
dress up or
like what is the when does it become a
fetish i mean this is not going to be a
uh
a good answer you know but i just think
it feels
right
come right in okay
when it feels like you'll take
anybody with that one thing
yeah quality
out the window just any person
oh she like very skinny or she has a fat
ass or
asian or also when i hear asian i think
when i hear asian fetish i think it's
like this typical
asian features whereas
the last asian girl you dated you
wouldn't know she was you wouldn't know
she was asian right and that's something
they're not all those things about like
their dosa it's like that shit's from
the 1600s man like that shit's done
but
she's got a nice butt
people have butt fetishes or boob
fetishes and that's fine but if you have
skin tone or cultural fetishes that's
off which i just get like i don't i
don't [ __ ] know i don't know i it's
as a guy who never got to have a type
um
i just i it's like pop politicizing this
stuff feels a little rude to me yeah
where it's like i don't know people are
just trying here i don't know who cares
that's the other thing it's it's chris
always says like women always want to
know why
it's like i don't [ __ ] know i love
you is that good enough but why do you
love i don't [ __ ] know what what do
you like what do you love about me right
like what
just you want to eat or not yeah i'll
pay for dinner and then we'll [ __ ] you
and then hopefully it'll be good and
then
i the cultural stuff
i i don't i know that i don't have to
take this [ __ ]
and we're ending this podcast right now
this happens not the whole
series goodbye
[Music]
[Music]